[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode
Arisa fury today I am so excited I've
been waiting for this moment this guest
doesn't live in state so we've had to
coordinate it for a while he is one of
my favorite comedians of all time and
his podcast middle somewhere quickly
became my favorite comedy podcast give
it up for Chad Daniels hello thank you
so much oh nice yeah you know who we
need as hay bales I know everybody and
this is actually our first time meeting
it is which is weird to me I feel like
we've kind of known each other I feel
like I know a lot about you from your
podcast but excellence um I'm honored to
finally be in the presence of cookies
and cream cookies and cream yes that's
right feel so good simply inside jokes
going on everyone watches like the
hell's happening
I'm like you're a lot of using cream
that's true
between mine and yours I wish that we
could have gotten like a hooter
sponsorship okay so what is your
foosball experience when I was younger
my mom and dad were in a bowling league
okay and so when there wasn't school and
there was on Sunday night when it wasn't
school on Mondays I was allowed to go
with them because it was ended up at
like 11:00 or something and this guy
named Donnie bragger who's like one of
the funniest guys I've ever met doesn't
do stand-up just very funny he taught me
how to stuff your mittens in the goals
so you only had to pay for one game the
entire night beautiful and that's uh
it's about remember no skills just the
con part of it
why do know that you can't they call it
putting it in the blender or is that
right you can't do this
oh I've never heard that term before if
I like it
Wow looks like somebody doesn't know
everything there is to know do you want
to take one of my trophies now I think
that's what you get was one of them say
I know what put it in the blender oh I
know you're gonna come on talk [ __ ] if I
can do it well not about business that's
why I'm trying to get my jabs in
anywhere other situation
and I know you're super competitive I am
very competitive
and I told you this before yeah I'm not
gonna come in here and lay down but I
also know I'm about to get my ass kicked
okay but it's like one of those things
it's like I tell my kids you can't like
to lay down for stuff because not only
does it make you look like an [ __ ]
it kind of takes away from the win it's
ours the win and that's not fair to the
other person so oh so like you're gonna
lose hard for me I'm gonna try my
hardest to beat you knowing I can't yes
correct like my son is almost 21 and
he's and still never beat me in horse
because I refuse to allow that shift to
happen in my house but when he does it's
gonna feel great right like if someone
came on here to beat you
yeah they could quit whatever they're
doing that's true they become the new
house what I jump off a bridge well I
don't know if we needed to go there but
you are for my Washington State so
here's the thing I talked with your
co-host of the podcast sure sigh
Amundson huh another great comic who's
okay he he told me that you would be
severely downplaying how good you are at
this okay because and you said this on
the podcast recently that you are good
at bar sports because your dad was an
alcoholic true and he would take you to
the bars a lot I consider bar sports to
be pool in darts sure but that's fine
you don't consider football well I don't
think they ever had it where I was
except the bowling alley okay so it's
like you're a foosball what's the thing
that you probably ping-pong okay
although Judah Friedlander kicked my ass
so bad at Moontower in Austin yeah it
was embarrassing he's in cahoots just
like I'm playing with a real champion I
was so excited delighted you're even
though this hurts but it's still kind of
cool I wish we had a ping-pong table
here cuz I how great would it be if I
beat you at that dude no [ __ ] chance
zero chance
[Music]
so we're gonna play okay one game to
five I brought his first round just kind
of see how it goes okay and now I'll go
for that all right okay
so would you like to have the ball for
no putting it in the blender no but that
means spinning thank you so much you're
welcome and do I want the ball first I
don't know does it matter
we can't spin it in there can you no so
how it starts now even though they they
manufacture them with a hole sometimes
you put it on your five bar you ask your
opponent or five bar oh [ __ ] yes I just
know that's a goalie okay and this is
what do you call this a two bar you can
a three bar what do you call well people
refer to this as a five bar I mean
people say rifle don't [ __ ] the Nerds
refer to this as a five normal people
are like it's the one with the you know
most people my mom and her world table
soccer Dominik are you sure
all right people refer to it my mom
wrote a book and I'm helping so you say
ready your opponent says ready and then
you're supposed to touch the ball to two
men wait a second okay
it's just so that people don't set it
there and then do that sure sweet block
I don't know if you got that on camera
gasps block no hands what's up
[ __ ] Jedi vlog and so that way it
just prevents that it's a little bit
very Karate Kid to me like we have to
bow to each other ready ready okay all
right you ready
I is that a trick I'm ready okay and you
have to touch it to two people then we
go touch two men and I win something
yeah oh no give it right back
oh [ __ ] look at me giving it back damn
it yeah that's right you're gonna be
spiraling very quickly I told you I
missed I told you in text that I wanted
to get you to charades level anger oh
that's it that's a good way to start
with this stuff you call it us stuff
yeah sure you did
that makes sense I feel good protests
ready what if I miss my second guy okay
now I can go oh yeah I told I wanted you
to get you a charades level anger
because that was so loud ready ready
okay well I can't even get it past your
five no it's three nothing stuff from
the high bar laughs is that in the book
stuff from the five bar oh I didn't say
ready oh nice shot after work wide open
net you [ __ ] missed what up punk
oh good I hope I can square from the
back on you great now goddamn it
oh hold on can I put okay it stopped can
I tell you something the [ __ ] ball
whizzes when you hit it it goes well we
can old yo-yo okay
you just put it here like here you go I
know that seems weird but that is
actually what you do in a professional
match because there are dead zones maybe
this is why this has not been an Olympic
sport yet I don't like that you're not
moving your men at all okay so that was
the first game yep that is open okay
how'd that feel oh it's [ __ ] 5-0 what
do you think it sucks I just want to
know because you said that you know you
were knowing that you wouldn't win by
just I'm wondering if like there's some
anger building at all I was trying I
mean I did think that maybe this was a
fake guy with like this thing was paper
that's why I checked to see if there was
a hole there because I felt like you
should've been able to score there but
you still did and I hate football
[Music]
all right come on over we're gonna do a
second round we're gonna make it easier
for you to beat me
okay so spin this a little bit and then
now you grab one and I grab one okay
[Applause]
what'd you get
I got a four okay so you hate this one
you can score on either goal
did you see the Steve Rannazzisi episode
I can swear on my own goal yeah well
that's ridiculous and it counts the
point for you
so I have to be able to play I have to
try and play defense both ways cuz if
you just pass it back you can just put
it in your goal and that's a point so if
you shoot at my goal and I have it with
my goalie I can just turn around and hit
it in my goal this is stupid let's do it
yes I have to play not only do you get
to do that but I have to play with my
arms cross and standing on one leg if
I'm gonna tell you something right now
if I could yeah do you want to start
with oh you want me start it you can
start with a question sure if you hit my
goalie and it goes in does that come for
me no Catherine its whoever's leading
whatever you're about to say it seems
like cheating mm-hmm like I'm actively
shooting it and you kind of block and it
goes in I mean that's still like it was
my shot no what's would you feel good
about yourself taking in that point if
it after getting beat five to nothing
yeah I would you ready okay
oh you have to do that that's right AHA
[ __ ] okay ready
you just call me tits oh hold on like
you know it technically happens what oh
it goes to me yeah back here yeah I'm
just I'm trying to be up here okay you
get it yeah I mean technically that's
how that happened so it's yeah you can
put it in your own goal mm-hmm
oh you know what you can score with your
own goal I do yep but I'm not gonna do
it on that one that was really that's
pretty shitty okay your [ __ ] arms are
crossed you're on one leg you look like
an idiot right now
if I lose I'm gonna go nuts I block it
with my own guy oh I can now I can score
yeah god damn it I hate this punishment
oh you're that Shh all right first time
oh okay
I'm cuz I'm gonna get pissed if if you
beat me in this round even though it's
so rigged I still will get upset great
I can't imagine I'm going to lose this
round Sean Patton beat me in the middle
around and he started with four points
and I still was upset almost all okay I
also I went on Instagram and asked
people to send in questions for you sure
so someone wants to know what oh my god
this cannot be happening I should have
scored that [ __ ] goal of myself
alright okay so now you have it oh okay
so I have to try and different both
because you can go either direction
right now okay okay oh I gave it right
back
I'm so nervous when I get the ball okay
so me wants to know the story of your um
what is it your Chester the cheetah
tattoo uh-huh sure
so this goes back to you technically so
I went in my buddy fritz his dad like a
strange fog had a tattoo parlor so I
said I'd go down there with him and I
because he wanted to like hang out with
his dad and stuff and so we're in there
and his dad's just like you guys want
tattoos we were like yeah we're 18 of
course we do and then he ended up like
what do you want and I go I'm eating
these Cheetos I mean makes sense to put
this on my body forever so I put chester
Cheetah with the Herschel Walker Jersey
favorite football player playing for the
Philadelphia Eagles favorite football
team at the time what's up can we see it
sure right now or is this part of a
challenge I don't want to see it right
now okay it's faded you can oh my god
that's amazing
pretty good I remember hearing the story
the podcast but I'd forgotten the
details of it and I'm glad somebody
asked it's pretty gross this is my cat
arm
I haven't arm dedicated to cats what's
up with that what's the tiger this one
well this one's real lame they're gonna
hear it yeah all right so after my
divorce is when people make their best
decisions naturally Derek it's time I
wouldn't got a I've always wanted that I
love Tigers but then I got instead of
some of the stripes
I got words that have been used to
describe me at some point in time good
and bad and then it's like a tiger can't
change his stripes kind of a deal and
then my whole plan was to cross some of
them off with stripes proving you can
change your stripes but guess what I
just haven't done it it's four years
later I'm like yep still enigmatic you
know me Oh mr. secret oh my god you know
that I do like the biggest [ __ ] you to
therapy ever like I'm gonna try and
change me word this year [ __ ] you oh my
god okay I'm ready are you ready yes
okay
Oh Oh always we got a little [ __ ]
table role here huh interesting
[Laughter]
I also can't tell you the number of
messages I got from people saying until
Chad Amazon cool Ronnie can you for
people who don't know the podcast
can you explain what that's all about
yeah no remember yeah he looks real
disappointed boom brought it back Shh
now I don't like you shushing me my my
my sister is a nurse okay my dad any
husband yeah has been gone for a while
he took off and so sometimes we don't
this is not good so we don't know a lot
of family members on his side this guy
came in with her
myname Daniels and she goes oh that's my
maiden name where'd you grow up and he
named the town where my parents were
born yeah and so she was like do you
know this person who was our grandpa
that we never met yeah and he was like
yeah he's my brother so we have this
uncle Ronnie she just met at the end of
his life and she's like do you want to
meet him and I go no I'm hoping to meet
a guy and then go to his funeral thanks
anyways I got a bummer I got other [ __ ]
going on I gotta go lose at foosball to
someone standing on one leg with [ __ ]
arms crossed are you ready let's go it
just always goes right back to you
come on come on hold on you're just safe
focus this is like this my wallet yeah
you're damn right I'm taking it now all
right absolutely you're killing me
you're you're winning okay you ready
[Applause]
this is way easier I like this much
better let's do this for the third oh my
god you didn't take it that was that you
being nice or is that just that you want
to win enough that's not maybe a nice it
just feels a little lame okay hey why
don't you hop on over here no I got it
that's probably a real bad decision on
my part you ready yeah from the fire bar
is that in your [ __ ] mom's book from
the fat ales from the five bar that's
one one now what do we do
yeah I felt great your body lit up
not waiting you beating you did not feel
great scoring from here felt great it
wasn't I shot
it's nice you to say
[Music]
we're gonna play ball okay where we each
start with the ball we hit it on one two
three go I'm gonna hit it you have to
score both balls to get one point so
huge for one it's a wash
here's the thing if you lose yep I spoke
with psy and we were just trying to
brainstorm what a great punishment would
be for you I hate how many times he's
been brought up in this it's just it
felt right because it felt like if psy
was on I would be texting you'd be like
how can we ruin his well don't you easy
make him stand for three minutes without
someone giving him a massage or some
horseshit okay so if you lose you have
to drink you don't have to drink the
whole thing but you have to drink some
of a milkshake a vegan cookies and cream
milkshake with a shot of vegan ranch in
it and a shot of whiskey in it because
apparently Acme comedy club
Branch Daniels Ranch Daniels mm-hmm so
you wanna do it well so what is the
thing behind this oh there was just a
guy that he was at the time he's lost
weight now but he was a big dude just
using his body as a rental vacation
house and he was like will you give me
five dollars if I like lick some ranch
and then do a shot of Jack Daniels like
a weird new tequila shot and I was like
I'll get five dollars from everybody in
here if you blend up ranch dressing and
Jack Daniels and then chug it out of the
lowball and he was like yeah of course
and so then he did it pretty early in
the night and then we just all stared at
him and we were just waiting for like
Vesuvius just like all right look at his
eyes they're watering this is gonna be
amazing never puked really yeah
what a [ __ ] tank yep impressive okay
so so you're gonna have to do that
cookies and cream in honor of your tits
and not over my tits yeah but I want you
to know that what we were gonna have you
do is so much worse because first
there's something in me that just I want
to see how far I can push you because
you get somehow did it just
oh it's like I have a dad all of a
sudden I just want to push you to be
your best so originally we were gonna
make you wear well tell me what you tell
the camera what you told me beforehand
what you think you wouldn't do do things
I won't do I won't wish illness on my
children even if it's for fun and I
won't get naked in any in any sort of
way okay I shower with my shirt on when
I'm all by myself okay so what we what
we have do we have it right now that I
could show him yeah we're gonna we're
gonna grab it mmm my initial idea was
let's get a like a woman's white tank
top that is so funny oh [ __ ] that is so
funny because it's also like that extra
the what does it call the middle I
should think so yeah I mean I'm gonna
disappoint double stuff double stuff
thank you I'm actually my brain just
fried because I saw this that's
fantastic and I don't I think I'd have
some nice cleave in that Oh beautiful
yeah there are times where like it'll be
gray skies in Minnesota for two weeks
and I for cereal I will pour a sleeve of
Oreos into a mixing bowl and then put
milk on it and just like well this is
how we die it's super disgusting but
also what's that son sees guys ladies
all right so my initial idea was I
wanted you to put us on I specifically
was like can we get one with a built-in
bra some sort of support I want a little
cleave and then we hot glue gun Oreos as
nipples amazing and oh it gets it get so
much worse so we bought a lawn chair we
were gonna have you lie down in the lawn
chair and eat the concoction off of your
own tits that's before before it was the
whiskey ranch version I was like what if
we found like what if somebody was
willing to give us their breast milk and
I was gonna make you drink a breast milk
cookies and cream milkshake and I text
about to sigh and he just dinner
spawn and I was like it's very still
laughing that's why I'm like maybe
that's too dark maybe that's too much so
then we reeled it back to the
cookies-and-cream whiskey ranch but we
were still gonna have you wear this and
lawn chair and eat it off your chest and
then you said that you wouldn't do
nudity and I was like I feel like this
is there's two different looks right
there's the standing look if I'm wearing
that and you know when you can see
somebody on a windy day and they have no
idea and you're like oh the belly button
portion of that shirt is discolored so
we can see the crater that is that
person's belly button that's my standing
look in that I guarantee it and then
sitting I would just constantly be doing
the fat person like cuz this listen I'm
not in the worst shape out of anyone in
the world I understand that but when I
stand up I've had to start doing the fat
person take away where you pull your
shirt out a little bit I can't stand it
you have body dysmorphia you look like
you're in fantastic okay we're done
let's take let's play let's go
I feel like you're more uncomfortable
with me saying that to you than if I
like which rice your roast that is
unbelievable I think I would actually
just so it doesn't go to waste
I'll eat those Oreos well we want you to
take it with you I mean souvenir of your
trip oh [ __ ] that's so funny
thank you I'm glad I brought you joy it
would have brought me more joy to see
you in it but sure I'm sure I'm trying
to respect to your boundaries and that
makes sense you still do have to eat a
terrible milkshake so I get I get
something out of it yep so now do we
need to even really play this one okay
okay are you ready okay one two three go
it went away so quickly I said I didn't
hit mine that was a mistake I was trying
to hit it just for a second that was
like when you win the low hand in pie
Gow you're like bring it on you [ __ ]
ass and then all sudden we're hope okay
are you ready one two three go
you got that one huh [ __ ] wait took a
point I'm so used to taking the point
sorry that's okay
makes sense hey ready go one two three
go
[Applause]
damn are you right-handed or left-handed
it depends what day it is I also had a
lot of messages about your cookies and
cream tits and then somebody asked me if
they felt like you had an unfair
advantage because I would be distracted
by your supple well I should have
probably worn that shirt but you gotta
show you a little cleave you know what's
up I would have changed everything
completely different outcome from the
tales from this bar myself to Motown
what's the song called tales from the
five dollar okay ready one two three go
back to you you can't score in your own
cool this time okay I went ahead I went
to Provincetown and Cape Cod the summer
with my daughter okay and she and she
like I had on a fanny pack and provost
owns a very gay town yeah and her story
interrupted with a sick cross-court shot
still 0-0
and I had on like flip-flops and cutoff
jean shorts and a tank top
not with that kind of stuff but then
also a fanny pack
and my dad was like what are you doing
and I said I'm gonna go dangle some
daddy bear bait and uh and any time we
walked by a group and anyone would look
at me my daughter would go dangle dangle
I know and it just reminded me because
he said something like uh I think he
said angle you go angle and dangle
dangle your daughter why is she not a
comedian
cuz she's 16 and you won't let her know
I would rather my daughter do
pornography than stand-up comedy I think
there's more respect is your bed all
right Wow I'm gonna barf before the
cookies and cream milkshake interesting
why do people ranch no no it was my
daughter it was make-believe sleeping
with someone in my bed damn it um when I
realize I completely forgot part of that
middle round where you could score on
either side I was gonna also say that
you had to talk in size the whole time
and I forgot I just kind of want you
will you just do it like for a point
yeah that was a pretty good shot right
there
I keep getting in the way of my own shot
I gotta learn how to get my guys out
cause that's a goalie shot oh I'm gonna
lose but I am taking away some positive
things I had a cross quarter which was
sick as [ __ ] plus then I just scored
from the goalie oh wait a minute
I scored the first one oh [ __ ] oh no
this is great
this is this is really fun thank you for
having me on
[Applause]
100 nobody scored you Oh with if we
measure the last two goals of mine it's
probably they're probably over 40 feet
if you combine them I scored from the
goalie and then call this the tube are
in the league how's it going 1 2 3 oh
[ __ ] that's like when two people used to
duel and they both got shot at the same
time like who won that [ __ ] about that
just lie in there that's incredible
that's pretty but I don't I don't get
why you were able to keep doing that on
me because I'm setting on my defense so
that doesn't okay ready 1 2 3 go okay I
know that's great and you did a great
job there but you're frustrated you're
exhaling in a way that leads me to
believe you've been to a class for it
and then also you just go oh what and
that's like a little some little kid
shoot when you turn the channel from
their cartoon oh I'm in your head right
now and it feels great I just wasn't
expecting you did get any well so this
is kind of upsetting me
ready mmm 1 2 3 go oh I [ __ ] was that
should've been in case
oh stop subtle stuff like those Oreos
baby you do that's right oh okay what is
it to do one kind of oh yeah
ready yep one two three go block the
block again by my own guy that gets old
oh that [ __ ] you do hit it really oh I
bet you hit it really hard from the back
the cup section is gonna lose their
[ __ ] wine anytime I tell I'm sorry
you were in the middle of a story
[Laughter]
that's the thing I'm taking from this
what how did he get there dammit
any time I tell the guests that they
have good D the comment section loses
their [ __ ] mind so that's a new one I
guess okay
he ready one two three go [ __ ]
five bar sorry I'm swearing so much
foosball a web series your your fine to
say whatever my guys have been playing
such good defense for you okay hun you
scored that first one so even if I make
this this is a wash
it's a taking way too long
Oh nuts oh that was pretty close I can't
I'm having trouble even just like making
a conversation with you right now
because cuz you're concentrated just
yeah I get it
that's pretty hard shot all the way back
yeah that was fantastic
what do you do today Chad oh I sweat in
a room that was 58 degrees huh
interesting
I don't know how this is happening I am
a lathered up in my shoulder blades
right now okay somebody else wrote in
our hammer take one two three go
somebody wrote in and asked like of all
the times that you said something snarky
to somebody in public has that ever
backfired like have you cuz that's a
pretty common theme of the podcast is
that you and I yeah say thanks to people
sure that I don't know how either of you
just aren't in jail all the time I can
feel like that should just be the show
it's like I thought the sketch we're not
in jail the scariest moment of my life
well two of number one people were
running I was teaching my son how to
boogie board and people were running up
to the beach and pointing and I saw a
dorsal fin and so I've never moved so
fast in my life
and it ended up being a dolphin so
that's the scariest moment of my entire
life but I also some guy was trying to
fight me at a gas station and I sprayed
his pants below his knees with gasoline
yeah and I was like so nervous I waited
for him to come back out cuz I'm like if
anyone lights a match or anything if he
goes too close to the hotdog stand
he's gonna start on fire and I'm gonna
have to be here for that so
sometimes it can backfire just in the
way that you're worried for a little
while and I'm very lucky I don't have
the anxiety or anything like that but I
was really nervous about that guy
starting on fire you do it was like
that's it's so fun to hear because I
would be terrified to ever do anything
like that it's freeing it's nice okay
ready one two three go oh look now it is
quiet time there are no more questions
it is just ass whoop City one two three
go so I was right he's like she's gonna
downplay how good he is I'm not I don't
think I'm good that's true I mean is
this it's taking longer than it should
to be you so that says something maybe
should I just keep complimenting you
with that [ __ ] you have more problem no
not about that it's a several I might
have come out actually I gotta stop oh
[Applause]
oh oh you its son
yeah it you have to those are the rules
all right you ready okay one two three
go how do you see everything oh that was
great
good match my hands are freezing
[Laughter]
yeah what's wrong that didn't feel good
that's fun
I mean it was a win but it didn't feel
like it you know your son I've just been
trying to stall because I know I have to
drink that goddamn shake that's my issue
yeah oh look here it is it's so nice to
look how nice it thank you so much so we
got vegan cookies and cream ice cream in
there
sure a shot of vegan ranch and a shot of
whiskey what kind of whiskey dad I don't
know see who can adn only the best who's
you guys go to the plastic bottle store
Jesus Christ did you try this you can't
see arms folded wide athletic stance and
just how much you have to drink like
half of it describe it so you know what
okay I can taste the whiskey the whiskey
actually kind of taste nice it kind of
masks the fake chocolate sure whether
ranch since I was a child has always
tasted and smelled like what happens in
your mouth right after you vomit it's
like that lingering that tastes like my
food and then you go back you're like oh
that's vomit it's like that part of it
it tastes like ranch yeah you go to
college
did you mix up the ranch or put it in
the middle like one of those Dairy Queen
it's mixed in there okay cuz I just got
a huge shot of it oh you know what
though I hit that speed slot yeah that's
nice mm-hmm let me take a quick drink
and then talk to you where it gets
skinnier it's not as much oh yeah that's
true
I really don't like what happened on the
table today just saying you know that it
it affected our schedule today because
now the thing is hot to start later
because yeah I took too long well why
did it take too long you were given an
option do you want to talk about the
option that was given no okay I mean I
mean I will if you don't want to people
asked like maybe we played a three
because it was taking so long and then
you said all right let's that's fine and
then I said well you need to explain to
everyone that we're gonna play the three
but we started at five because you can't
beat me that fast and then you said five
and then it took I don't know fourteen
point six seconds to get your last three
goals just let me know when I break the
record for this game of how long I've
held her off should we just play two
three I can't I can't believe it's
taking me so long to be is actually
really ruining my day to be fair if we
played a three I'm gonna need you to say
we started at five and you can't be me
so we have to go three didn't do it
something's happening right now in my
this in here half
okay more mm-hmm oh yeah you're good now
that's a little more than half but can
you picture right now you on a lawn
chair
cookies-and-cream tank top what are you
doing you know what since you let me off
the hook without nudity thing ah I'll
finish oh you're good man
that's a good manner there mm-hmm I know
a lady who my kids call mom might
disagree with it I'm going to trash that
count
now what would have happened if you came
on I didn't speak to you previously
about the nudity and I said hey you have
to drink a cookies and cream milkshake
made of breast milk off your chest what
would you have done in that moment off
my chat like we're gonna dump it in my
tits
I'm just gonna spoon it like a bowl of
cereal yeah we bought wet lights cause
like first of all we could have taught
kids about glacial shift because it
would have looked like this ice cream
just moving through a valley we're like
and this is how rivers were made great
he says the F word but he also teaches
would you have had it if I made it with
breast milk mm-hmm that's a yes well I
would like to see some like HIV testing
and all that stuff that goes along with
that person that came from but I would
really god damn it I wish we would have
done that I feel like I have to do a
great job I'm for sure gonna vomit I can
feel it right here no I think there's
more than a shot of ranch in there I'd
like to talk to God again
oh yeah that's stuck awesome it's like
you know that little trapdoor that lets
food in mine absolutely just went weep
no Road closed we're gonna leave it
right here and then you can just puke
that out stomach wants no part of this
and you have really long ago oh man I
this has been the best oh can I have
that thing the oh yes please please God
bring this bring this out
oh hey this is everything
oh my god I am soaking wet right can you
plug anything you want to plug here hi
you can follow me on Instagram you
probably see this on there that Chad
Daniels also my website is Chad Daniels
comm for live dates and I have a podcast
called middle of somewhere where you can
listen to it and then get all the inside
jokes that happen to you today like
these cookies and cream tits yeah for
example well really going for it you can
follow me on instagram at Kelsey cook
comedy Twitter is at Kelsey cook you go
to kasa.com for tour dates and please
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and watch the rest of the
episodes thank you so much thanks for
having me this is really fun okay good I
will see you guys next time bye thank
you guys for watching another episode of
erisa fury be sure to pick up your
official erisa fury shirts that they are
buttery soft they feel like Dalton skin
they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below free shipping
[Music]